El día 15 de septiembre de 2021, los líderes
de Estados Unidos, Reino Unido y Australia
anunciaron un histórico acuerdo.
Quizás el primer paso para llegar a cambiar
el curso de la historia.
Por sorpresa y sin previo aviso, los 3 líderes
presentaron AUKUS, la última alianza militar
del planeta.
Gracias a este acuerdo Australia convertirá
a su armada en una de las más poderosas de
todo el mundo gracias a la incorporación
de nuevos submarinos nucleares.
También se hará con misiles Tomahawk y participará
en el desarrollo de armas hipersónicas, tecnología
cuántica y sistemas de inteligencia artificial.
Con AUKUS la arquitectura militar en el indo-pacífico
está experimentando toda una revolución.
China, Corea del Norte y Francia han mostrado
su rotundo rechazo.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, el presidente de
los Estados Unidos, Joe Biden ha descrito
las relaciones entre los Estados Unidos y
la República Popular China como la contienda
del siglo.
(“Xi Jinping y otros autócratas, piensan
que la democracia no puede competir en el
siglo XXI con las autocracias, porque lleva
demasiado tiempo llegar a un consenso.
"Estamos en competencia con China y otros
países para ganar el siglo XXI.
Estamos en un gran punto de inflexión en
la historia”.
Joe Biden)
Y no se trata sólo del Presidente.
En Washington son pocos los que tienen dudas:
el indopacífico es con mucha diferencia la
región más importante para el futuro de
Estados Unidos.
Podemos hablar de Ucrania, Turquía, Rusia,
Venezuela o incluso, México, pero lo cierto
es que a la hora de la verdad para los Estados
Unidos de América el juego importante se
sitúa en esta otra región del mundo:
(MAP)
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Es precisamente aquí dónde están concentrando
casi todos sus esfuerzos.
Por ejemplo, a principios de marzo de 2021,
el Jefe del Comando Indopacífico, el Almirante
Philip Davidson, solicitó al Congreso casi
30.000 millones de dólares adicionales para
reforzar la arquitectura militar de Estados
Unidos en la región:
(Hablamos de nuevos sistemas de radar de alta
frecuencia, centros de intercambio de inteligencia,
depósitos de suministros y un nuevo sistema
de defensa antimisiles AEGIS en la isla de
Guam.
Y eso no es todo.
Las fuerzas armadas norteamericanas también
tienen intención de construir una nueva base
en Micronesia, reforzar su presencia en Guam
y junto con Australia levantar una base conjunta
en Papúa Nueva Guinea.)
Pero no penséis que se trata solo de nuevos
equipos militares… Hablamos también de
nuevas políticas.
Por ejemplo, Estados Unidos está animando
a Japón a desarrollar armas hipersónicas
y mejorar su fuerza de misiles;
ha renovado su acuerdo militar con Filipinas
y acordado un paquete de 2.600 millones de
dólares en armas;
y en mayo anunció la suspensión de las restricciones
que obligaban a Corea del Sur a limitar el
alcance y la carga útil de sus misiles de
producción nacional.
La idea es que sus socios locales consigan
mejorar su capacidad militar.
Pero Washington también quiere reforzar sus
alianzas.
Por eso en los últimos años ha impulsado
nuevos acuerdos militares con países como
Vietnam, la India o Tailandia.
Al tiempo que también está reforzando alianzas
e instituciones como el QUAD o Five Eyes - de
las cuales ya os hemos hablado en VisualPolitik.
De hecho, se especula con que Washington se
estaría planteando incluir a Corea del Sur
en Five Eyes, en la alianza de inteligencia
que comparte con Australia, el Reino Unido,
Canadá y Nueva Zelanda.
(“Debemos convencer a Beijing de que los
costos para lograr sus objetivos por la fuerza
militar son simplemente demasiado altos" Almirante
Philip Davidson, Jefe del Comando Indopacífico)
Pero con todo, quizás el paso más importante
de todos es AUKUS.
Este acuerdo militar a tres bandas implica
que Australia se convertirá en toda una potencia
militar con una de las flotas de submarinos
más poderosas del planeta; también se equipará
con misiles tomahawks - los cuales podrá
lanzar desde los propios submarinos.
Y todo ello al tiempo que comenzará a colaborar
estrechamente en el desarrollo de nuevas capacidades
militares y tecnología punta: inteligencia
artificial, misiles hipersónicos, tecnología
cuántica, etcétera, etcétera.
Es decir, todo apunta a que a partir de ahora,
ese selecto tándem de confianza, influencia
y poder formado por Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido incluirá un tercer miembro.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué este acuerdo puede
ser tan importante?
¿Por qué precisamente Australia?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Qué implicaciones puede tener para la región
más importante del mundo?
Atentos.
(EL AMIGO MÁS LEAL)
¿Por qué Australia?
Pues, principalmente podemos destacar dos
razones de peso.
Sobre la primera de ellas ya os hablamos en
un pasado vídeo, aquí en VisualPolitik:
Australia, el país del surf, los canguros
y la ópera de Sydney ha demostrado ser históricamente
el mejor amigo de Estados Unidos.
Quizás no el amigo más fuerte ni el más
poderoso, pero sí el más leal.
Australia, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
es el único país del mundo que ha luchado
con Estados Unidos en todas las grandes contiendas
de la potencia norteamericana:
En las dos guerras mundiales, en Corea, en
Vietnam, en la Guerra del Golfo, en Afganistán,
en Irak e, incluso, en las operaciones contra
el Estado Islámico.
Además Australia es un país rico y muy próspero
que cada vez tiene más recursos, por ejemplo,
para gastar en seguridad.
De hecho en 2019 este país se convirtió
ni más ni menos que en el segundo mayor importador
de armas del mundo, tan sólo por detrás
de Arabia Saudita.
¿Y a quién pensáis que le compra el grueso
de las armas?
Exactamente: a la industria militar norteamericana.
[Digamos, que últimamente a los ejecutivos
de empresas como la Lockheed Martin, la General
Dynamics Corp, BAE Systems, Raytheon o la
Northrop Grumman, cada vez que ven a un australiano
se les abren los ojos de par en par.]
Y para colmo Australia está relativamente
próxima a una de las zonas geopolíticas
más importantes de todo el planeta.
Es decir, que puestos a escoger un nuevo socio,
¿qué mejor opción?
Y de hecho, eso es precisamente lo que Estados
Unidos lleva haciendo desde hace años.
(En 2011 los dos países firmaron un importante
acuerdo militar que, por ejemplo, permitía
el despliegue de una fuerza de combate de
hasta 2.500 soldados norteamericanos en el
territorio australiano.
Y desde entonces la relación no ha hecho
sino hacerse más y más próxima.
En 2019 Australia acordó con Estados Unidos
una compra superior a las fuerzas aéreas
de muchos países:
72 F-35; 11 aviones de guerra electrónica
EA-18 Growler, aviones de alerta temprana
y aviones de transporte C-27J battlefield.)
Además recientemente ambos países también
han acordado incrementar la presencia de aviones,
buques de superficie, tropas y submarinos
de Estados Unidos en Australia.
Es decir, el amigo más leal sigue siendo
el más leal de todos.
Así que os hago una pregunta: ¿Qué mejor
candidato para compartir con él buena parte
de tu tecnología militar más avanzada?
Pues… Dicho y hecho.
Bien, este es el primer motivo.
Pero dijimos que había 2.
Pues bien, el segundo tiene mucho que ver
con China.
Y es que veréis, durante las últimas décadas
Australia fue un país que mantuvo tan buenas
relaciones con China que según parece algún
alto funcionario chino que se la podía tratar
casi como una colonia.
Lo que con el tiempo se ha demostrado un grandísimo
error.
Según contó el propio Primer Ministro de
Australia Scott Morrison en el Wall Street
Journal, el gobierno chino le exigió tajantemente
que pusiera solución a una lista de quejas
chinas si no quería sufrir un duro castigo:
Aranceles, campañas de descrédito contra
el país, amenazas, robo industrial, espionaje,
la interrupción del turismo… Es lo que
se conoce en los círculosinternacionales
como la Diplomacia del lobo guerrero.
(Para evitarlo el gobierno australiano tenía
que abstenerse de pedir una investigación
internacional sobre la Covid-19;
dejar de bloquear inversiones de empresas
públicas chinas en infraestructuras estratégicas
de Australia o censurar a los medios de comunicación
para que dejaran de publicar noticias que
le molestaran al régimen chino.)
Casi nada.
Básicamente exigieron que Australia entregara
su soberanía y su libertad de expresión.
O cuanto menos que las limitará.
Y, amigos, la respuesta de Camberra, fue un
NO rotundo.
El caso es que las relaciones se enfriaron
tanto que el gobierno y la sociedad australiana
comenzaron a ver a China como un peligro potencial.
Había que protegerse.
Y, ¿Sabéis que?
Justo ahí estaba el amigo norteamericano
y también el amigo británico con la mano
tendida para brindarle al país toda la protección
que necesitarán los australianos.
Y así, así es exactamente como se gestó
AUKUS.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Viendo las reacciones y la falta de temple
que hubo en China tras el anuncio, no se,
no parece una mala idea.
(Frente a una Australia tan irracional, ¿no
debería China prepararse con puño de hierro
y golpearla fuerte cuando sea necesario, enseñándole
una lección completa?
Hu Xijin,editor jefe del diario estatal Global
Times.)
Ahora bien, hay una pregunta que nos queda
por responder: ¿Por qué este acuerdo puede
ser tan importante?
¿Qué implicaciones tiene exactamente?
¿Cómo puede condicionar el futuro de Asia-Pacífico.
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(SONRISAS Y LÁGRIMAS)
Queridos amigos podemos destacar 3 implicaciones
o consecuencias directas de este acuerdo que
podemos sintetizar en 3 ideas:
La nueva Australia, China y Francia.
Si os parece, sigamos exactamente este orden.
Australia es un continente insular, con una
inabordable costa que llegado el caso puede
resultar difícil de defender.
Además, en una época en la que los buques
de superficie son cada vez más vulnerables
al ataque con misiles, es algo casi universalmente
aceptado que los submarinos de alta capacidad
jugarán un papel clave en los ejércitos
del futuro.
Hasta ahora la estrategia predominante en
Australia, era la conocida como continentalismo.
Esta es una estrategia que centra sus esfuerzos
en defender al país de una agresión militar
directa.
Bajo esta óptica, tal y como apunta el profesor
Hugh Wihite de la Universidad Nacional de
Australia, el país no necesita grandes submarinos
nucleares, sino que le basta con submarinos
convencionales más pequeños pero más numerosos
para defender las costas.
Además está sería una fuerza que por sí
misma, al no tener alcance suficiente, trasladaría
un mensaje claro: Australia no está interesada
en incursiones exteriores.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, la decisión
de apostar por submarinos nucleares implica
un importante cambio de postura y objetivos.
(La gran ventaja de los submarinos nucleares
es que pueden permanecer sumergidos más tiempo
y que tienen más espacio para portar más
armas y más provisiones.
También, por regla general, son capaces de
navegar sumergidos a mucha más velocidad
y operar a profundidades mucho mayores.
Todo esto supone una doble ventaja: por un
lado las incursiones son más sigilosas, por
otro lado, pueden estar desplegados más lejos
y durante mucho más tiempo.
Es decir, su misión puede ir mucho más allá
de la mera defensa de las costas de Australia.)
Por ejemplo, se ha calculado que los actuales
submarinos convencionales de la clase Collins
de Australia apenas podrían pasar poco más
de 11 días desplegados en las aguas del Mar
de China Meridional, mientras que los nuevos
submarinos podrían quedarse mucho tiempo.
Es decir, en caso de ser necesarios con esta
nueva flota de submarinos nucleares, los cuales
además podrán lanzar misiles Tomahawk a
objetivos en tierra, podrían apoyar fácilmente
a las fuerzas norteamericanas con misiones
de vigilancia, protección o ataque.
Y eso no es todo.Con este acuerdo Estados
Unidos envía también un importante mensaje:
si tienes miedo de las represalias de China
aquí estamos nosotros.
No sé, ¿Qué queréis que os diga?
Parece una buena jugada.
MEl caso es que hoy por hoy solo 6 países
operan submarinos nucleares: Estados Unidos,
Rusia, China, Reino Unido, Francia y la India.
Australia será el séptimo.
Una situación que en China no ha gustado
ni un pelo.
Y es que últimamente los líderes chinos
no pasan por su mejor momento:
Tienen peleas o discusiones con prácticamente
todos sus vecinos.
La popularidad del país entre la comunidad
internacional se ha desplomado, entre otras
cosas por acciones como la toma de Hong Kong
o la persecución a minorías;
El crecimiento económico se ha desacelerado
y el riesgo de un estallido descontrolado
de la burbuja inmobiliaria está sobre la
mesa.
Pese a todo, hasta ahora los líderes chinos
estaban acostumbrados a una determinada forma
de relacionarse con sus vecinos: si les criticas
o no les gusta lo que haces te castigan.
Qué se lo digan a Corea del Sur, a Taiwán,
a la propia Australia o incluso a Lituania.
(Cuando China y Estados Unidos pelean, es
Corea del Sur la que recibe el golpe.
LATimes)
(Lituania se queja de las "sanciones" comerciales
de China tras el conflicto de Taiwán.
FT
(China sanciona económicamente a las industrias
australianas en medio del deterioro de las
relaciones.
Business Standard)
Sin embargo, en el caso australiano el tiro
les ha salido por la culata.
Y eso, eso es algo que sienta un mal precedente
para sus intereses y sobre todo para su forma
de relacionarse con el mundo.
Y este es precisamente el motivo por el que
el gobierno de Xi Jinping ha calificado a
AUKUS como una amenaza “extremadamente irresponsable”.
Incluso se han sucedido declaraciones de rabia
pública como esta:
(Armado con submarinos nucleares, la propia
Australia será blanco de posibles ataques
nucleares en el futuro [..] ¿Realmente quieres
ser un objetivo en una posible guerra nuclear
o quieres estar libre de la amenaza nuclear?"
Victor Gao, un influyente analista geopolítico
chino)
Sin embargo, más allá de la furia en los
micrófonos, muchos analistas militares chinos
[conscientes quizás de la metedura de pata]
le han querido restarle importancia:
(“La tendencia general actual de integración
económica global es muy diferente de la confrontación
y división entre los dos campos durante la
Guerra Fría [..] El pacto eventualmente mejorará
las capacidades de combate de Australia y
ayudará a los Estados Unidos a ampliar su
alcance militar, pero no representaba una
amenaza inminente.
Hu Fengsheng, analista geopolítico chino)
AUKUS, amigos, no es ni mucho menos un acuerdo
tipo OTAN.
De hecho esa no es propiamente la estrategia
de Estados Unidos en la región.
Y es que veréis, la acumulación militar
de China es innegable.
Durante las últimas décadas ha desarrollado
y producido cientos de misiles balísticos
de largo alcance y su marina es ya la más
grande del mundo por número de barcos.
Sin embargo su hegemonía en la región no
es tan grande como podríamos pensar a simple
vista.
Por ejemplo, sí, la armada china es la más
poderosa de la región pero apenas representa
en torno al 30% del tonelaje naval.
Los esfuerzos de países como Corea del Sur,
Japón, La India, Taiwán, Australia o Vietnam
entre muchos otros hacen que la competición
esté mucho más reñida de lo que podriamos
pensar.
Especialmente si cuentan con el apoyo decidido
de Estados Unidos, que es precisamente lo
que ha ocurrido con Australia.
Una enorme metedura de pata de Pekín.
Así que una sorprendente consecuencia que
podría tener AUKUS es precisamente rebajar
la tensión en la región.
Por último, la tercera consecuencia directa
tiene que ver con Francia.
Un país que se ha molestado mucho con este
acuerdo, ¿por qué?
Pues no solo porque le hayan dejado de lado
- y no olvidéis que si algo molesta a un
francés es precisamente que le den calabazas
o que le hagan de menos en la esfera internacional
- sino también porque le ha supuesto perder
un negocio enorme.
(AUKUS ha supuesto que Australia rompa un
contrato de casi 65 mil millones de dólares
con la industria militar francesa para construir
12 submarinos convencionales tipo barracuda.
Y además lo ha hecho por sorpresa.
Algo que el propio ministro de relaciones
exteriores de Francia calificó como toda
una puñalada en la espalda.)
Para muchos, Londres y Washington han aprovechado
el momento para saldar cuentas.
Unos por el trato sufrido durante el Brexit,
otros por el tinte norteamericano que en los
últimos años ha tenido la política exterior
de Francia.
En cualquier caso, sea como sea, lo que viene
a demostrar esta jugada es que Europa cada
vez pinta menos.
Queridos amigos, amigas estas son las claves
y las implicaciones de AUKUS, el acuerdo militar
que refuerza no sólo a Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido en el indopacífico, sino que conviertirá
de facto a Australia en toda una gran potencia.
Eso sí, tendrán que esperar… Los submarinos
no estarán disponibles hasta finales de la
próxima década.
Claro que una nueva jugada de China puede
terminar confirmando esta noticia:
(Australia considerará arrendar o comprar
submarinos existentes a los EE.
UU. o al Reino Unido.
Australia Sky News)
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué te parece la operación AUKUS?
¿Cómo valoras esta estrategia de Estados
Unidos de empoderar a sus socios en el indopacífico?
¿Cómo crees que responderá China?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios.